welcome to our special online exclusive
roast battle we've got our judges Nikki
Glaser
[Applause]
mr. Jeffrey Ross our first challenger is
considered the best battler in New York
he's been described as unbeatable by
everybody except his preacher father
from NYC by way of Mobile Alabama give
it up for the menacing men tonight high
standards
[Applause]
[Music]
was that an entrance or you just kind of
got lost there for a second his opponent
is considered the best battler in LA
he's the only dad whose dad jokes are
actually funny
he puts the beat and diabetes and the
dye in he's going to die of diabetes
[Applause]
[Music]
what an adorable Amber Alert
nice Pat you brought a snack gentleman
who wants to go first no I got it
just to be clear that was my son I had
to get him out of here before the battle
I didn't want him to think that Daddy
was fighting with Grandma
Eli is actually only 33 years old dude
you are aging terribly you look like
you've been drinking from a fountain of
youth filled with Flint Michigan water
number one dad baby how are you making
fun of how anyone looks you look like
someone who tweets compliments to porn
stars now that that was actually Pat's
second son Pat your first son who will
remain nameless because he was a
miscarriage you guys had a miscarriage
after you'd already baby-proofed the
house it worked a baby didn't get in
look when I lost a child I had to pray
that one day I'd be able to have another
one when Eli lost a child he had to pray
that that child didn't go to the police
yeah no matter how did you come back the
kids still want
Matt your father passed but look at you
you died would be proud you did what
your father always wanted to do you
killed your son
[Music]
hey everybody what's the difference
between Eli's girlfriend and a KKK hood
I don't believe he lies ever been inside
his girlfriend you grew up in Philly
Philadelphia is known for a lot fresh
prints on dead minorities very religious
so he'll be back here in three days to
watch that joke rise again
[Applause]
yeah man yeah I'm religious man you
should understand the Trinity because
for you the Sun and the ghosts are the
same person if you look up the word
retard in the dictionary you'll have
open more books than Pat
[Applause]
let's joke yeah that was that was two
bombs in a row typical New York move
putting two things back-to-back and then
watching them collapse
great man you uh yeah you think about
9/11 a lot that's your goal weight
no more miscarriage jokes Pat plays
fantasy baseball that's when he imagines
playing catch with his dead son
[Applause]
there were so many miscarriage jokes I
saw Anthony get an erection and take
care of it
yeah first of all Pat I loved how you
came out right away and traumatized your
child for for television exposure that
was great and Eli it sounds like you're
really good at this you made a choice
tonight to go after the miscarriage hard
none of us know who the Pat Barker
is much less that he's had a miscarriage
with his wife anyone who does has also
had a miscarriage with Pat's wife so I
think you just made the wrong decision
on it to be honest I'm happy the
dinosaur jr. let you off for the night
to come and be here but I think Pat just
had the better strategy and I give it to
Pat he like you went so hard even when
the audience turned on you I never
turned on you I loved that joke
about him opening up the dictionary I
thought it was a great joke that was
maybe one of my favorites so I don't
know what's wrong with me as soon as I
was like man this is too much
miscarriage stuff you addressed it which
I loved and we're like listen I'm gonna
lay off and then you landed another one
and I love you for it and so I'm giving
you the wind because you're ruthless and
crazy yeah break this tie between the
west coast and the East Coast Pat I know
your wife's in the house so we got to
give her a big round of applause
for having sex with him why are we
applauding her if Eli taught us anything
isn't that she's a failure in the face
of adversity you know you get you take
all these really mean jokes and stride
you obviously have thick skin under all
that blubber so Pat Barker
congratulations
[Applause]
subscribe never a rose-petal podcast
whatever podcast we will see more is
exclusive visual only horse battles the
future alone
[Applause]